I'm willing to bet that if if we didn't
have if contraception was no longer part
of the picture most of the cultural
interest in BDSM would go away you know
most of the choking most of the
role-playing most of the other ways that
people look to put the danger and the
intensity in to a sexual encounter which
has been sort of neutralized we need to
give sex back the seriousness that it
that it has and this this for me means
the feminist case against the pill
now I'm now I'm to be clear I'm not
making the argument for
for
um
taking legal measures against the
contraceptive pill because that's just
nowhere near the Overton window but but
I but but you'd like to
those are your words Francis not mine
um well what I do think we can do at
this point is just lean a little bit
harder into something which is already
happening which is a female particularly
young gen Z female backlash against the
pill and that's that's a phenomenon
which I've been tracking for some years
um
and I mean I was genuinely shocked to to
hear how the the her usage and
prescription of these really quite
mind-altering medicines has changed
since I was in in adolescence I mean
when I was when I was a teenager if you
went to your GP and said can you put me
on the pill you'd get them you'd get the
third degree about you know are you in a
steady relationship and you know X Y and
Z and you know is an appropriate
relationship and do we need to talk to
your parents and so on and now as far as
I can make out you know it's it's pretty
routine you know for GPS just to stick a
girl on the pill at about the age of 15
and that's just it and there's a there's
a book that came out last year I think
um is it called your your brain on the
pill or something anyway so it goes into
goes into just how radically
mind-altering the effects are of this of
this drug
um it changes it changes who you find
attractive it changes your your entire
hormonal cycle it changes your attitude
it can have major mental health
implications for young women whose
brains let's not forget are still
developing
um you know the the downstream you know
the the mental the psyche the psycho
psychoactive impacts of this drug are
immense I mean I was on it briefly and
you know and and I stopped in my early
20s because I I just realized it was
making me fat and sexless and it's
low-key insane and I was just like it's
just not worth it you know what what's
the point of taking this thing so I can
have sex if I no longer enjoy having sex
what am I doing now I think I'd rather
just not not have sex with men which is
um the solution which I adopted for a
number of years
um
so
these now we're seeing a growing body of
young women who are saying I don't want
this and who are embracing you know less
less invasive you know less psychoactive
you know non-non-hormonal contraception
or just cycle tracking and my argument
is that this is just where we have to we
have to start here you know don't take
the pill don't encourage your friends to
take the pill you know reject reject
this idea that you can't be a person
unless you make sort of fun radically
psychoactive cyborg interventions in
your own body
um and and there are a number of things
that follow from that in terms of how
how you relate to other how you relate
to men and to your own sexuality and one
of them is that you know of necessity
you become choosier about who you sleep
with which from women's point of view
when you think about the amount when you
think about hookup culture is obviously
beneficial because one of the things
that women complain about is is ending
up ending basically consenting to
Loveless or degrading sex because they
just there's no obvious reason to say no
and you know if you if you sort of
neutered yourself sexually by by taking
this medicine you know being
this there sort of is no reason to say
no and and sometimes it might just seem
polite to put out
um which is a pretty pretty kind of grim
position to be in if you're a woman I
think
privately I think a lot of a lot of what
flew under the metoo banner was
basically was basically this this
um there's young women who ascented to
things sort of out of politeness or
found themselves railroaded into sexual
encounters more or less out of
politeness that they couldn't say no to
or didn't have a robust enough reason to
say no to because they were already
contraceptive and if you're in a
situation where there's a meaningful
risk of pregnancy you know that's a
pretty solid motivation for saying no
actually no actually I'm not coming home
with you or no you know I'm now I'm here
you know I'm we're not doing this and
it's also you know for all for all but
the most you know straight out toe rag
it's a fairly robust reason as a guy to
not go there as well I feel like I'm not
on birth control and I'm not going to
use birth control you know you're not
you're
yeah it would it would take a fairly
serious a fairly serious scumbag anyway
so so it it reduces it reduces the
opportunity for bad sex which I think is
obviously in women's interests
um it also makes sex better
um you know if you're as speaking as a
woman you know I'm not going to give you
Grizzly details and I'm too old and ugly
to you're talking about this stuff
anyway but if you're in tune with your
own Cycles you just it's just nicer you
you you know you know where you are and
you know there are certain kind of moods
go up and down over the course of a
month in ways which are interrupted if
you're on the pill
um and but but
I think one of the and taking that a
little bit further
it's my view that
you can't have you can't have the
intensity and the mystery and the beauty
of a sexual encounter without the danger
um the fundamentally
we should we we take sex seriously or
have historically taken sex seriously
because there's the potential of
creating another human and once you take
that out of the picture
um something something strange happens
to the entire field of sexuality and
again I can't prove this because it's
just a hunch but I'm willing to bet that
if if we didn't have if contraception
was no longer part of the picture most
of the cultural interest in BDSM will go
away you know most of the choking most
of the role-playing most of the other
ways that people look to put the danger
and the intensity in to a sexual
encounter which has been sort of
neutralized it's kind of vegan bacon
equivalent of of the sexual encounter
you know it's almost it's almost the
same but not quite and so you have to
add more hot sauce and that's where you
get all of these you know escalating
escalating levels of degrading
disgusting kind of Kink and
and extremities to people trying to add
the hot sauce back into something which
is fundamentally vegan bacon and you and
the the the obvious solution if you're
starting to get a newer to the hot sauce
is you know have the bacon but that
means you have the dent you put the
danger back in
and uh and I called this say I don't so
I don't think of this as a purity-based
argument against contraception I think
of it more as rewilding sex you know and
when you when you're in in an ecological
context when you talk about rewilding
that means sometimes introducing apex
predators back into an environment I
don't know if you've seen that amazing
viral video about what happened when
they when they introduced wolves back
into Yellowstone and and they had all of
these incredibly complex
effects on the ecosystem which ended up
with a river changing course because the
the the deer followed different patterns
and then other things happened in a
different pattern and eventually you
know things things writed themselves in
in a whole ecosystem which hadn't which
had been going slightly wrong before and
and it couldn't have happened without
the apex predator back in so I've sort
of I've used that as an as an analogy
for thinking about how we can correct
some of the things which have gone wrong
in our sexual ecology by by
reintroducing the the danger and the
intensity
um I mean this is this is a risky
argument to be making I feel like I'm on
genuinely heretical territory here but
you know essentially I'm making the
prosex case against contraception
foreign